So, 67, I'm going to 75 from
Ah, so
there's a little known model that many
are saying is actually better than
Claude. It's called GLM 5.2, and a lot
of SEOs are using this model and using
the Hermes agent to actually do SEO task
and write SEO content. So, in today's
video, I'll be using this model and I
will be comparing the output quality
from Claude Sonnet and see which model
gives us the best outputs. So, I've gone
ahead and added in this model onto Word
Rocket, so we can actually go ahead and
test this out. So, if you want to test
it out, you can test it out in the
generate content um template. So, we see
here, this is from the ZAI GLM. 5.2.
This is the first article in which we're
able to get back. So, what's to do on
Canada Day in Niagara Falls? So, as you
can see, it actually looks really,
really good. Um decent content. It was
able to do our keyword Sorry, our um
perplexity research, take that
information, write the full article.
Did it include internal links? I don't
know if I turned it on, so I'll have to
double-check that. Let's go back over,
and this was the article that we got
back from
Sonnet. So, as you can see, to be
honest, just from looking at it, there's
not much that separates these two
articles. Uh the Claude Sonnet was a
little bit uh longer. So, what I've
actually went ahead and done is we've
opened up this keyword on NeuronWriter.
So, NeuronWriter is a content
optimization tool. So, essentially,
we've entered in that title.
Okay, so we've Let's go ahead and
generate our title.
We're going to generate our meta
description, save changes.
So, this article here is the article
from uh Z.AI, so GLM. We got a 70 out of
100. So, not bad. Right? So, 70 out of
100 right out of the box the box. And
this is the article from Sonnet. So,
Sonnet gave us 71 out of 100 while we
got 70 out of 100 from
uh Z.ai. So, not a lot uh to kind of
separate them. Now, if you actually go
ahead and let's go ahead and take a look
at our credits. I'll go to our logs. So,
we'll be able to tell the price
differences. So, we see GLM costs 0.03
and Claude Sonnet costs 0.13.
So, there's definitely a price
difference. Um Claude is 13 cents while
GLM is not even 10 cents. It's about 3
cents, right? So, 3 cents versus 13
cents for an article. So, a big
difference there
in our cost. So, GLM is definitely less
expensive and if it gets the task, you
know, 80 or 90% there compared to um
Claude Sonnet or even 90 to 95% there,
then you may think about switching and
using um this model over Sonnet for
certain task. So, again, I've went ahead
and I've done another um comparison here
between two different topics. So, here
is the second article in which we wrote.
So, it's on uh peptides or different um
research compounds. So, this is the
article from Z.ai. Again, it looks
really good. We get the quick answer,
key takeaways. We get the GEO optimized
questions, tables.
Everything looks pretty pretty
comparable to what we would get back
from Sonnet. So, this is the topic here.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the
original article. Again, there's really
really not much other than maybe the
length. This article seems a bit longer.
Sonnet does write a bit longer um than
GLM. But again, there's not really much
to separate these two.
So, I'm going to copy this over. We're
going to head back over to Neuro Writer,
and then we're going to do the same
thing and we're going to do a
side-by-side comparison. So, this is the
article from Claude Sonnet.
We got a 67 out of 100. So, 67 out of
100 from Claude Sonnet.
And this is from GLM 5.2. So, 67, we got
a 75 from GLM.
Uh [sighs and gasps] so,
it is looking really, really good. I
think we're going to add this in um
permanently because as we can see the
price differences, right? Like the
difference is pretty the delta's pretty
big, right? [clears throat] In some
cases, it can be a little bit less
um just depending on how long the
content is. So, there is kind of a a
price difference or a cost difference
between the two models, but we see here
that um in this example at least, we see
here that GLM actually scored higher
than Claude Sonnet. So, let's do the
last article test, which is uh a
difference between do two different
compounds here. So, we're going to click
generate to generated the title, the
meta description. We're going to head
back over to Word Rocket. We're going to
copy over our topic here. So, this is
from GLM 5.2. So, we still got 53 out of
from GLM. So, now let's go ahead and
we're going to copy over the article
from Sonnet. So, Sonnet got I think we
got a 50 something, 53, 57. Sonnet got a
48.
So, yeah, Sonnet actually did a little
bit worse when compared to GLM um for
this specific keyword as well. So, in
two of the three tests, we see that GLM
actually scored higher than Sonnet. So,
we'll definitely keep this in and you
guys try it out for yourselves and let
me know what you think. Um I'm going to
be doing a lot more testing as well.
This is just kind of, you know, some
some beginning testing. So, I wouldn't,
you know, completely change my stack,
but it is something to definitely
consider. Hope that you guys enjoyed
today's video. If you want to try Word
Rocket for yourselves, head over to
wordrocket.ai and give us a try if you
haven't already. It is the best content
writing tool in the market. And we've
just launched our AI visibility, so you
can also track your AI mentions across
the internet. Hope that you guys enjoyed
this one. I'll see you in the next one.